hey it's alex what's going on it's eric
we're about to be on truth or dab i'm
nervous af the episode is going up watch
it now check us out check it out
hey what's going on everybody from first
week feast i'm shawn evans and welcome
back to another exciting episode of
truth or dab the hot one special where
we give our guests two simple options
tell the truth or suffer the wrath of
the last app and today i'm very excited
to welcome alex gwyneshelly and eric
adjapong she's the food network mainstay
you know from iconic shows like chopped
and iron chef america as well as her
midtown manhattan restaurant butter he's
the top chef finalist and co-founder of
pension plate and together they tag team
the cooking competition series alex
versus america which returns for season
two on food network very soon alex and
eric welcome to the show oh my goodness
sean thank you for having us we're so
excited we're like super fans that we
can't believe we're here yeah well i
hope that we're friends still at the end
of all of this and let me explain what's
going on here so you guys have a plate
in front of you some wings they've all
been doused in various versions of the
last dab i have a set of deeply personal
potentially awkward questions for each
of you and when i ask you a question you
have a choice answer it honestly or
escape the truth by eating a death wing
and alex
we're gonna start with you what if you
lie
can i just like i guess we'll never know
i guess we'll never know you know
thinking back on all the cooking
competition shows that you've done
whether it's recurring judge or a guest
cameo who is the most savage or intense
food critic you've ever come across
i don't know if you can say that out
loud
who's the most savage
ruthless
i mean it has to be scott conant it
really does i mean that guy is just like
he laughs he's like oh this is terrible
and you just watch you know young chefs
careers crumbling like buildings so i'm
gonna say scott conan and he's no longer
my friend
too yeah no longer my friend and it was
worth it
all right eric we're gonna switch over
to you
and a chance to throw some bombs
yourself jeez
you're a finalist on top chef season 16
competed in season 17 all-stars
be real of all the judges that you came
across which one had the worst palette
the worst oh my god
how's that wing looking
oh
man um do you have any blue cheese
dressing geez
[Music]
i'm gonna have to say
not the worst but the hardest to figure
out no he said the worst oh my goodness
all right i'm trying to switch it up you
know what um
i would say the worst palette then would
probably be
sorry graham graham elliott yeah
probably
we are friends are dropping like yeah
yeah it was tough to just find his like
sweet spot right and and figure out what
exactly it was that he appreciated in
food so i had a really like uphill
battle trying to figure out for other
people like with padma's ethereal with
tom it's like craftsmanship with with
graham i was just like i don't get it i
don't know i don't know um it's a wild
card yeah he's a wild card hard to
figure out shout out to graham shout out
to chicago yes legit moving on to the
next round and so far unscathed okay and
in round two i have a question for both
of you so feel free to talk amongst
yourselves but i'll need separate and
individual answers in order to avoid
eating a wing you're not making this
easy whatsoever all right let's do it
you've both worked in michelin-starred
restaurants run acclaimed kitchens of
your own i'm curious what is a fine
dining up charge or trick that you think
most disproportionately benefits the
restaurant over the diner oh that's easy
breakfast
you can charge like 30 bucks for
breakfast and an oblate cost what two
bucks yeah but it costs eight hundred
dollars to pay the guy to make it
right
what do you feel like i feel like it's
time to eat a wing yeah i say let's go
for it but appetit bon appetit let's do
it it is happening what are you going
for it's going down number one right
mm-hmm all right we're diving into the
apollo
always curious
that's not bad a little spicy spicy a
lot of
spices i feel all my inhibitions going
into this wing
this is a slow creeper that's what
happens with this one yeah oh my god
it's cooking now mom is that you
remember in zoolander when he had to get
his hair cut when he was when they did
the walk-off
whew
that's intense it's still going
wow i'm going to start drunk dialing my
fourth grade boyfriend
it's time for some milk
and you know what things are only
getting spicier here as we move on to
the third round
alex yes we're gonna stick with you all
right it's impossible to deny the
influence of food network personalities
but
in your opinion yes which food network
superstar is the worst restaurant or
restaurants oh
my god are you serious
i don't understand
do you not want me to talk did you just
call me here to eat
i have a front row seat
you got it you got to take the second
one right i can't yeah you got to go
straight i can't answer that right eric
little private meeting
can i have it can i talk to him about it
can we yeah can we for the front um what
do you think lifeline should we do it or
not i mean
now it's we let's give the people what
they want
i can't answer that you can't answer
that
i'm doing a total class move
many many thoughts
many many coursing through my vans
and you know
so
sean is this supposed to be hotter than
the last so here on this show you know
on on hot ones when you do the the
10-wing gauntlet you can kind of creep
your way up you know it's almost like
you're sitting in a hot tub it's going
up one degree at a time this show though
such a steep ramp up because we just
start at 10. so it's like no matter
where you go here it's just total soap
choice like no matter what you eat it's
just gonna be
this is like a jacuzzi in hell it really
is oh my god sweats
that looks like going in
wow that's a decent bite well i mean we
are stuck
i don't want to get that that's a really
strong bite all right and eric i noticed
that you took a bite there it's like you
ate for alex's question i actually have
a question for you i'm ready for it
let's do it all right know that you're
working on a pair of cookbooks right now
indeed
to avoid eating a wing here i want you
to pick out a title okay a widely
available cookbook that you think is the
most over hyped or overrated based on
the quality of recipes in it
were you up all night seriously um what
what are you piercing are you a shrink
are you a are you a channeler from
it's a therapeutic experience so a
cookbook that's overly hyped in title is
the hot sauce kind of clouding your
brain right now i'm going inside yeah i
don't know if i'm there oh jeez really
you can't you can't think of one
oh look i saw that devious that was a
devious can we can i could you all right
tell me what do you think eyebrow pop
from alex i mean i can't you can't say
what i think i don't want to say it i
have something in mind
chefs are pirates like you can't give
away the secrets of the black pearl i
know but that's the magic of this show
the magic of this show that is intense
not as hot as the first one
just wait curious i'm curious your
thoughts are from a culinary perspective
like on these kinds of sauces um i'm
sweating now number one these are like i
like spice i like heat um
this is just like five alarm though this
is insane i think i'm drooling yeah like
all you're like i'm i'm sweating now the
satellite like the south salivating as
well like
um but
the wings are good like these are some
solid wigs other than that like the
weeds are delicious
um this is tough the food is so far
surpassing the hospitality of your
questions i know you know i feel so bad
because you started off on such a good
foot you know and then this is what
happens i you know it's it's a burning
bridges show and i'm a burning bridges
host you know just by inviting people
out here
we're we're we're going to have you for
dinner after this i know i don't know i
owe the paperwork what do we should only
be eating sean
that's a good question yeah it's going
to be a tasting
all right moving on and we have you guys
eating wings let's let's try to draw it
back a little bit
you're both cooking competition pioneers
but we know not everything is as it
seems on tv can you give us a trade
secret a pull behind the curtain
something that would shock your average
viewer
commercial breaks stuff that happens
like in between shots right it's a true
production i think a lot of people don't
realize like there's a culinary team
there's a art department team there's a
there's a audio and visual right so
there's a true like production going on
and i feel like a lot of people don't
get that because they're watching the
commercials and the ins and outs like
the food that the judges are eating has
happened
there's a show
in the show i feel like during the
commercial break what about you my whole
childhood is flashing before my life
because my whole mouth is burning my
first instinct is to say i've never
eaten a plate of truly hot food all
right you know that's interesting we can
trade notes on this because i always
think logistically it's complicated to
do food within a show you know it's it's
hard like to base on like when the time
is gonna be to eat it you know there's
so many there's so many spinning plates
that it is hard to
snap that rubik's cube into place and
when people make ice cream if it's
desserts
if someone makes ice cream and someone
else doesn't i've seen chefs fight over
the fact that the ice cream was held in
the freezer during the judging that kind
of small nuance right
can set a set of blaze let me put it to
you i mean it seems applicable
i should speak but there's other types
of hot ones and i don't mean wings
but yeah hot food hot food all right we
are moving on here to
it's the final round it was quick it's a
sprint here on truth or dab all right
what i want to do is a collective
thought exercise on that side of the set
over there okay i want you to close your
eyes and through this hot sauce-induced
fever dream
think about the most insufferable
one-star yelp rant or critic review that
you've ever read about yourself i want
you to identify that pull quote that
line that still irks you to this day
tell us what is that line what is that
pull quote and what would you say to
that person if you saw them on the
street today
[Laughter]
um
i'm having so much fun thinking about
what i would say
you go first um you seem to have you you
immediately react yeah i feel like it
was it was just one of those things it
was super busy friday nights in in
dc the restaurant and typically what i'd
like to do if i have 15 minutes in the
night go outside and shake hands right
just thank the people that take the
folks that just came out over the night
so i did that i was sitting with one
table speaking conversing whatever and
then i just happened to do so with the
table behind me the yelp review was
absolutely insane chef eric came out and
and greeted every table except for hours
decided the third and it was just like
the food was bad all of a sudden because
of that like the whole experience was
bad because of that and it's tough
because you can't be in everywhere like
all the time so that for me i think was
like the the toughest part i don't know
if that i don't know
um i have so many i i like i and the hot
sauce is really making it harder
i watch people on episodes be like i
don't know i blacked out there's a
there's a fog a hot sauce yeah you get
like a little head there really is
exactly someone hand wrote me a letter
and
had it brought to me in the kitchen
while i was cooking
and they had diagrams of the food they
had eaten and all the reasons why i was
so bad and then said
you should really think about going to
culinary school in the first place and i
was already running the restaurant
and they then took
their thoughts and put it on like a
17-paragraph yelp review
which somehow made it to the top of the
heap and you know how you call and
you're like how do we move this who do i
have to pay like what i'll bring my
child you can have her you can have my
apartment whatever and they're like i'm
sorry there's just like nothing we can
do it's like a free world as a free
country
we felt you should know how people feel
about you and i'm like
thanks a lot
to close things out here on truth or dab
season two of alex versus america coming
to food network this summer be on the
lookout you don't want to miss it alex
and eric thanks so much for taking on
the wings let's give them a hand
thank you guys can we fall over now yeah
i've been trying to act stoic
i'm tasting the other one oh go for it
what's going in
well i have to know yeah you have to
know you have to do
but did you have to know no
oh yeah i would have started with this
i was hot really yeah
you know what you're right you can eat
these and you're dying like you
literally see your whole childhood but
you can function yeah yeah right exactly
like some of those like just straight
extract sauces or whatever that's just
like dorm room that's alive yeah this
was so this was [ __ ] hot this is the
worst excuse me this is terrible
hey what's going on hot ones fans this
is sean evans checking in with a very
exciting announcement we've read the
comments we've seen the emails and after
six years more than 250 episodes we can
now bring you the full hot ones
experience in one convenient package i'm
proud to introduce you to hot ones
boneless chicken bites available
exclusively at walmart and walmart.com
each bag of hot ones boneless chicken
bites is packed with approximately 35
breaded seasoned white meat chicken
bites as well as individual packets of
the classic los calientes and the last
ab apollo for all your saucing and
dabbing needs the full hot ones
experience ready to heat and eat
whenever you get the craving to spice
things up at home
hot ones boneless chicken bites it's a
party in a bag and everyone's invited
[Music]
you